I hope you're ready to dive back into
the brains of some of gaming's wackiest
characters because Psychonauts 2 has
reached its 3.3 million dollar
crowdfunding goal Psychonauts 2 the
sequel to Double Fine's highly revered
platformer has reached the largest crowd
funding target goal for a video game
ever this psychonauts equal hit 3.3
million on January sixth with five days
left in its campaign as of now funding
sits at about three million three
hundred and seventy thousand bucks the
campaign ends on January 12 so if you
haven't yet back the game there's still
time to do so Double Fine revealed
psychonauts at the video game awards
last year the developer is known for
using Kickstarter but they took a
slightly different approach this time
around with big fig CEO justin bailey
said the Psychonauts 2 campaign is the
first video game crowd funding campaign
to allow unaccredited individuals to
invest in the development and publishing
of a video game and share in the
earnings this is the first of many
campaigns that will allow everyone to
financially share in a game making it a
true community experience psychonauts to
like the original is being led by double
fine's President Tim Schafer although we
don't have an exact release date for
when Psychonauts 2 is supposed to come
out it sounds like you're gonna be
waiting a while Double Fine sequel
stands in the top 10 highest crowdfunded
games of all time with star citizen
holding the top spot with over 100
million dollars are you as excited as I
am to finally see a sequel to
psychonauts for more on Double Fine
psychonauts and all things gaming you're
already in the right place